oh my god wow this is like adults more
[Music]
[Music]
sushi and beer two of life's greatest
pleasures but too often the go-to
combination devolves into pairing cheap
takeout California rolls and industrial
log this week's mission on that Tod
let's drink it is to create the ultimate
world-class sushi and beer pairing
matching each flavor pack piece of fish
and rice in omakase tasting with its own
perfectly chosen brew and there's no
better place to test out this
experimental approach to micro pairing
the New York City sushi temple shuka
where chef Jimmy Lau is the mastermind
behind one of the country's most
innovative tasting menu my name is Jimmy
Lau I'm a secretary chef from so called
New York City
I think it's um I wanted some new and
the place on the traditional that that's
a show called you should come here twice
most the sushi restaurant they about a
fish sushi rice wasabi and soy sauce I
more think alike how to make you know
not boring or I don't know how to call
her mom maybe I should choose a better
war but I only know it says boring
that's what we have this year the total
we have soo-ji with the chili papers so
something more like a music so up down
up down up down to feel different
Oh Mikasa it must mean like a leap to
the shelves it's a chef's choice it's
exciting because you never know what
he's gonna come out follow the news but
I never parroting omakase with beer so
this is new for me in kind of exciting
for this my partner on this journey is
my great friend Juliana barwick she's an
amazing musician who came to dogfish a
few years ago to create beautiful songs
incorporating the ambient sounds of our
brews and to help me brew a wasabi
infused ale inspired by our love of
sushi Juliana good to see you guys just
like we're back together in the big city
so this is gonna be like a fast-paced
greatest hits of shuka some of their
most famous creative recipes and paired
by the beverage director eric has some
beers that i've never even had before
along with a couple of our old favorites
take us on this journey chef let's do
this this is the author pollo Toro
usually it's sort of the grand finale
the fireworks are going off and it's the
end of the meal but you guys do it early
Sapporo it's always when it's tender so
we do the early because normally people
even suic they would talk and did not
pay much attention and I want to catch
you guys attention on me it's a total I
get catch attention like this isn't
gonna be your normal sushi meal do you
do that with like sequencing on an album
like in this era when so many people are
playing songs not whole albums
absolutely I mean I think a lot of
people still appreciate listening to an
album you know in its entirety from
beginning to end like so there I like to
think about the arc of an album here it
comes
this is a total yeah little fin tuna
from spam paired with the classic
quintessential Japanese beer Kirin
Ichiban let's see how this one goes
together hey
buttery soft decadent oh my god it's
hugging my tongue and this beer is
really super cool because they do it's
called the first press where when you're
brewing a beer
the barley and the water you kind of
make a juice called wort wor-tv
fermented beer and what we in America
call the first runnings is the sweetest
most intense part of the beer they call
this first press and while it's not a
challenging beer in terms of intensity
of flavors it's got that nice sparkling
malt backbone that I think works really
well with the fatty Toro what do you
think of that parent it's almost kind of
nutty like it the beers small do not
mean it goes with like sort of richness
of the dude perfect sensory experience
are you ready for round two
round two yeah so ocean trout with lime
zest and pepper pairing it with a wadi
Kuro so much like in the u.s. there's a
blossoming movement of Japanese craft
breweries this is one of them in the
same way that we're fearless with
ingredients these guys are actually
using a Sancho pepper
beer I get like floral almost like a
rose hip nose to this
radius a little bit occurring on the
town thicker than than the Karen right
yes that's why I also put a little bit
pepper on that there yeah cuz multi
sweeter beers tend to go well with
spicier foods it's like a little blanket
for your tongue yes I like the kick at
the pepper and lime on it
yeah the citrusy yeah the citrusy notes
are there that's a good bear yeah yes so
chef I understand this is one of your
go-to beers with asunción peppers to
have during service
actually that's my photography I never
say no for that this one is just seared
use the charcoal still Toro
yes do toto yeah but sear that were
adding like a little bit flavor from
Mohammed oak special Japanese wood yeah
and also a little be like a smoky frame
oh yeah this is like one of your
signature dishes you guys are known for
this and in the beer world
well we're known for this is our big gun
a beer that we brewed together before we
try this beautiful parent we're going on
a little animated journey to find out
how we made this beer back in 2014 I
teamed up with musician and sushi lover
Julianna Barwick to brute Rosati an
Imperial Pale Ale that gets an extra
layer of bitterness and complexity from
the addition of raw wasabi root we used
red rice from Giuliana's home state of
Louisiana to balance the spicy kick and
bracing bitterness with a kiss of
sweetness to bring things full circle in
2018 were busting out a vintage bottle
of rossabi to find out how its flavors
have evolved over time and how it pairs
with a Japanese delicacy that inspired
[Music]
[Music]
that's right woodsy it tastes like
hanging out in the woods it's like
campfire sushi so good and what do you
think of our beer cheers by the way
four and a half years ago roughly to the
day no sabe we brewed this together yeah
sure dad tell me what you think how you
think it's holding up I think it's
mellowed a little hops have receded
right the aromatics of the hops have
receded and this one kind of has a
little bit of a mommy thing going on in
our beer and I feel like there's a
little mommy going on the dish what do
you think yeah I think at once that you
see it and a change they're putting out
a total if it will mommy out yeah I
think it goes really well I think like
the woods enos of the oak and the char
and the tuna goes really well with the
earthiness of wasabi and our that we
made this yeah yes and you did this we
need it we did this it's our policy new
with Rio and over the chuckle and the
with that type of ITT hot chilies sinewy
tuna yeah paired with multi hoppy 90
minute IPA also charcoal II but wait
comes and just keep coming yeah are you
gonna yeah barbecue flavor yeah yeah
barbecue flavor for sure so good and
usually stronger beers amplify the spice
but ninety minute has both maltiness
sweetness to it and hops
it really is helping tame the spice they
go really well together
IPAs are kind of like the beer
equivalent right now of what tuna is and
sushi restaurants they're ubiquitous
similarly you guys
to know which people expect but you
brought it in directions I think no one
expected called a spicy Cunha very spicy
I think you
I definitely feel it right here so that
concludes today's amazing micro pairing
journey incredible do you have a
favorite I think maybe I think maybe
this last one was my favorite I mean
it's just so delicious I feel like I'm
smelling and breathing for the first
time up my senses right now chef Jimmy
you're good at what you do Giuliana bark
you were good at what yeah same to you
Sam this has been a fun journey
[Applause]
[Music]
you